the biggest ever team in League of
Legends continues to shock us T1 Korea's
second seed stomped Europe's top-seeded
bad lions in 16 minutes and 47 seconds
that's right game three was so fast that
it was shorter than one of the breaks
between games T1 looks so good that it
almost feels like 2016 all over again so
can Faker and this team do what they did
back then and have failed to do since
and win the whole damn thing
guys it's 16
no we don't
lose
[Music]
all right guys before we get into the
video just want to remind you that
liking the video and subscribing the
channel really does help and uh I don't
know maybe stay around to the end of the
video for a very fun question that you
can answer
for real there will be an inboard
question so after a season where they
seemed like destined favorites at Worlds
and then fell short T1 are again showing
us why they are such a scary League of
Legends roster not only did they beat
mad Lions 3-0 but they did it very
quickly so quickly in fact that you
might as well call it MSI glitchless any
percent speed run because
it was so fast it was incredibly fast
interestingly this series was also more
popular than any Series in 2022's MSI
except the final itself while Faker
obviously tends to draw crowds the
popularity of the series might have
something to do with the way that the
game started because mad lions were
giving EU fans a lot to cheer about
early now nisky under attack got the
flash available we'll be using it gets
the stun below thank you
we're able to turn that early Advantage
into a seven and a half thousand gold
lead over T1 but a disastrous team fight
saw that Gap narrow a bit and then this
happened oh my God please stop it
Take the Wheel
we're gonna burst it don't they
so after that pretty emotional start to
the series and a great adaptation by T1
in game two we got to see again exactly
why T1 is so scary
cannot defend their base at 16 and a
half minutes the Nexus turrets are being
destroyed the Nexus could be focused
it's up to chase it to defend it have T1
seriously what a game it's 17.
I have never seen my more dominant win
from a second seed taking down at least
he's number one in 17 minutes T1
embarrassed mad lions
like this game ended so quickly they
barely would have had time to surrender
because you could only do that after 15
minutes it's second fastest
International game of League of Legends
ever and T1 who were then called SKT
were involved in the fastest one but
they were on the receiving end at MSI
2019 and it was IG that was doing it to
him as excellent and popular as it was
this series provoked all sorts of great
responses from members of The League of
Legends Community too plus it's not
every day that you get to see a rift
Herald do the old FBI open up on the
Nexus turrets in Pro play maybe you see
it every day because you're like wood
League I don't know Iron lead but one
thing that it does feel like we've seen
before is a series like this as redditor
play pointed out the classic pattern of
throw away the surprise lead game one
struggle against the lck team's
adaptations in game two and get stopped
due to mental boom in game three is just
a Timeless pattern but could this
tournament break a pattern for Faker he
hasn't won an MSI since 2017 but but
he's a very different player than he was
back then and the roster around him is
completely different as well an MSI win
now could bring Faker back to a new
level of prominence with younger fans
who maybe didn't see him dominate in
those early years don't get me wrong I
still think he's the goat obviously but
his Legend can absolutely still grow
side note Faker actually played his
200th International Pro game during this
series and that's a huge accomplishment
for any pro player in this game and who
knows maybe Faker and Co could take the
momentum from an MSI win and bring that
into summer and even worlds he hasn't
won a World since 2016 but there's some
good evidence that this roster is
capable of doing it for one gumiyushi
the team's ADC was absolutely on fire in
this series and he'll need to be if he
wants to see success internationally his
ofelios is just really scary and you
could see it in the game one team fight
where T1 are down seven and a half
thousand gold
Yushi doesn't care two and a half
thousand one and a half thousand it's
secured by T1 Zeus is the immediate
Target that's all of a sudden the
Moonlight vigil five T1 have belted
through the hit points for now they've
stood Toe to Toe owner is forced away
Chase he finds him slicing Maelstrom but
it's at the cost of nesquik's life four
members of T1 going backwards they get
the hook onto the little hamster
cozy how the hell are T1 doing it they
managed to win the fight down seven
thousand gold now you're just running
for his life because he's trying to find
time trying to fight the feathers he's
boosting up Faker but he said he can't
do it gonna miss the next Target feather
storm out cause he wants to close it
over the album oh yeah somehow mad Lions
bring it back from the jaws of Team
fight defeat only 31 to shut them right
down this fight has gone on so long that
niski's been able to respawn and
teleport back in all of a sudden nisky
can he catch faker looking for the
incinerator that's into great but fakers
to tonkey turns it around again say us
the next Target depth charge again and
he can finally down let's get ready for
his life that's T1 it's T1 this is
madness all the shutdowns here going
over and carrier a support player who's
been called the best player in the world
and seems to carry games like a mid
laner sometimes was also red hot you can
expect to see this cleanse that he
landed on gumiyushi in highlight reels
for a long time
[Music]
all in all this team is looking so
strong that I have to expect their next
game to break records too okay so back
to those recurring themes another one of
those of course is an NA team getting
swept internationally and that reared
its ugly head when we saw C9 get swept
out by the lpl's Billy Billy gaming and
another N A Team golden Guardians was
swept just this morning by Chinese
Powerhouse jdg listen I'm sure this is
the part of the script where I'm
supposed to talk about how the Gap looks
more like the chasm or something but
ultimately I think that mad probably
learned a lot from this series and even
though he used top seed got blasted well
they have to figure out lck teams at
some point better now than at Worlds but
you know one thing that definitely won't
help if you make posts trying to
psychoanalyze the players based on their
facial expressions or just sling Venom
at them from afar come on guys let's be
better than this so what's next for T1
and mad Lions well this tournament
thankfully has a lower bracket so mad
Lions will go on to face fellow EU team
G2 yeah very unfortunate not great T1 on
the other hand will go on to face Genji
another lck Squad but one that is
notably never made it to an MSI Grand
Final despite that both lck teams have a
lot of history the Genji organization
formerly known as Samsung Galaxy is the
only other organization besides T1 slash
SKT to win Worlds more than once for
both LEC and lck fans it's basically
Alien versus Predator whoever wins we
lose
well one of us still wins I'm kind of a
glass half full kind of guy you know
what seems obvious to me is that if you
can get a series like we got in the
semi-finals well MSI could get even
better and if this is the year that
Faker hoists the Summoners cup you're
going to want to say that you were
watching along you're going to want to
say I called it plus there's always a
chance that T1 improves on their speed
run time
every year in the summer
there's a carpenter bee around my house
and carpenter bees are dope they're like
little bees they don't sting you they're
very curious about humans as well and I
guess what happens with these bees is
they eventually find a mate and they
just lead with their mate so every year
there's like one that shows up
um and I give it a name so
if you guys want to name my carpenter
bee put it in the comments and I will
pick the one that I like the most don't
do anything weird though okay okay don't
call it something like super weird but
yeah name my carpenter bee in the
comments if you got to the end of this
video and I will pick the one that I
like the most and I'll put at the end of
my next video that I do for down at me
cool